pub
[Musique]
tous
ce soir sur le divan d'henri chapier
amanda lear mai à londres
elle choisit les beaux-arts mais
l'étudiante passionnés devient à la fin
des années 60 la plus belle des cover
girl star du disco en france en
allemagne en italie et levant en 77 plus
d'un million de disques
peintre depuis toujours sa passion et
son talent font la conquête de salvador
dali mais la nouvelle ambition d'amanda
lear c'est d'être aussi un écrivain sur
le marché des animatrices de télévision
elle vaut un milliard de centimes par an
1 j'étais une petite fille de 7 ans
moche finalement oui franchement je me
trouvait moche parce que j'avais les
cheveux très raide javel et donc avancer
alors on m'avait mis un appareil qu'il
fallait resserrer temps en temps donc je
n'osais pas sourire je souriais comme ça
en me cachant j'étais trop grand de des
grandes et est donc déjà pour mon âge je
dépassais mes petits camarades
donc j'avais des complexes voilà il ya
un moment dans votre adolescence où vous
ai dit je vais construire amanda lear
c'est bien ça quand même
non j'ai pas voulu la construire mais
disons que j'ai pris conscience que je
voulais faire quelque chose que je
voulais devenir quelqu'un sa part
peut-être de complexe parce que tous et
complète créé dès l'enfance l'enfant
solitaire etc
voulant s'affirmer plus tard et j'ai dit
bon ben maintenant je m'en vais faire
tout ce qu'il faut pour devenir
ambitieuse et pour m'imposer dans une
certaine dans un certain activités
d'abord bon c'était la peinture puisque
c'est moi même mes premières amours
mais ensuite quand je suis passé au
spectacle il est évident qu'il m'a fallu
orchestré tout ça oui il a fallu
dire bon perdant dé lire comment je vais
la vendre qu'est-ce qu'elle a que les
autres n'ont pas c'était la voix bombay
justement j'étais mannequin et on me
disait tu sois belle et tais toi ne
parle surtout pas alors évidemment
j'étais mal parti pour faire découvrir
au monde cette voix rauque très spécial
très particulière que j'avais alors il a
fallu travailler et ce qui a eu un
encouragement de la part de vos parents
est ce que vous étiez une enfant très
choyé ce qu'ils étaient autoritaire au
contraire libre
etait-il tout à fait britannique on ne
sait pas tout cela non il ya eu aucun
encourageant tout d'abord j'ai eu des
parents qui seront séparés et qui
étaient de nationalité différente parce
que je suis britannique par mon père
puisque mon père était anglais travaillé
dans la marine de sa majesté et j'avais
une mère qui était d'origine slave même
mongol tous mes pommettes saillantes et
il ne s'entendait pas du tout ils sont
séparés et ça explique que j'étais
bilingue je parlais français avec ma
mère je parlais anglais avec mon père et
j'ai été vivre en angleterre et j'ai
gardé nationalité britannique
dans mes parents étant séparés et ils
m'encouragent et pas du tout à dans
cette voie de la mode du showbizz net
tout soit pas du tout ma mère plutôt
aurait été mais que je fasse des études
que je devienne probablement professeur
peut-être soeur docteur avocat a tenté
quelque chose de plus intellectuel que
le show-business évidemment on
n'imaginait pas à l'époque je finirai
dans des robes de payet sur le divan
d'un psychanalyste qui coûtent une
fortune chacun sait les psychanalystes
sans aucun problème au jour si j'ai
beaucoup de problèmes parce qu'à la fin
de la psychanalyse on éclate en sanglots
c'est connu et je parle de l'instant moi
je constate que bon vous pouvez les
d'avoir 40 ans vous l'avouer personne
n'avoue jamais son âge vous vous
l'avouer parce que vous le fais pas bien
sûr mais enfin il ya vingt ans qu'on
s'obstine à vouloir prouver que quelque
part je ne sais pas peut-être dans une
autre vie vous étiez un homme mais c'est
un peu vous qui avez initié tout ça non
pourquoi
dans une autre vie oui j'ai été un homme
en effet qu'est ce que j'ai
quelqu'un en italie une fois par un
voyant un médium à m'a dit que j'avais
été un soldat et trois italiens au xiiie
siècle et pillages avaient été une
esclave égyptienne très bon quand
plusieurs vies mais si on y croit
dans cette vie j'ai toujours été une
femme et j'aurais aimé être un homme
souvent j'ai pensé que la situation de
femme n'était peut-être pas le meilleur
deal la meilleure chose qu'on compte qu
on puisse rêver dans notre société
la légende vient tout simplement de ce
que j'ai fréquenté un génie farfelu vous
le savez c'est salvador dali qui
s'adresser à tout le monde au masculin
qui aimait beaucoup
vivre dans la confusion il disait il
faut vivre d'erreurs et de parfums alors
nous appeler mont garceau il le me
parlait au masculin comme il parlait au
masculin à une dame aussi qu'on appelait
louis xiv à une jeune fille chinoise
qu'on appelait le gars de rouge
il aimait beaucoup transformé les femmes
de sa cour en gentlemen en garçon est
donc bon ça prête à confusion c'est vrai
quand vous présentez dans une soirée
parisienne une ravissante dont vous avez
pu vous vous l'a voulu parler au maximum
disait il
or les gens disent à pont alors
peut-être que c'est vraiment da lire
c'est un travesti d'un tracé
transsexuels ceci dit la leçon m'a servi
l'idée m'a servi puisque sam samaha sam
a confirmé dans l'idée que les gens ont
besoin de merveilleux d'extraordinaire
et que pour vendre
amanda lear on pouvait cultiver cette
légende est gelée cultivait avec succès
pendant plusieurs années jusqu'à ce que
je me brûle le moi même dix on a à mon
mensonge parce que le jour c'est comme
quand on crie au loup
le jour où j'ai crié bon arrêtez
maintenant je plaisantais voyez bien que
je suis une femme une femme j'ai envie
de me marier comme tout le monde d'avoir
des enfants
les gens ont dit oui mais qu'est ce qui
nous prouve que vous êtes une femme
n'était pas seule à moi moi je vous
prouve regardez moi on me vous savez
aujourd'hui la chirurgie esthétique fait
des miracles et c est donc j'ai eu un
mal fou finalement à a écarté cette
rumeur qui n'a qui ne sera d'ailleurs
jamais complètement effacée puisque vous
savez que les rumeurs ont la vie dure
dans notre pays et donc je m'en
accommode allègrement et je sais que
quand j'aurai 80 10 ans je prendrais
dans la rue on aura dieu merci oublier
le titre de mes chansons mais on dira
mme c'est amanda lear vous savez bien
on disait que c'était un garçon et ça
tiendra c'est comme un chewing gum ses
comptes en marge on sait que vous
défendez beaucoup les femmes
alors moi j'attends qu'on vous décor du
mois que le mouvement de libération des
femmes vous d'accord vous avez dit
l'autre jour à propos de la peinture
vous avez dit il faut arriver quand même
à prouver qu'une femme peut peindre si
bien qu'un homme pourquoi est ce qu'une
femme ne peint pas hélas ce que vous
faites en pâture prouve
justement qu'une femme non bayer la
différence
je voulais surtout le prouver à salvador
dali parce que d'aller au départ avait
justement cette attitude très très
misogyne très machiste des des latins
les femmes n'ont pas de talent le talent
c'est une chose spécifiquement masculine
il faut avoir des testicules pour avoir
du talent les femmes n'ont pas
d'engagement bas talent alors dans le
domaine de la peinture bon c'est vrai
que si on regarde velasquez vermeer
rembrandt tout ça c'était pas des femmes
et il faut il faut réussir à d'abord
approuvé à dali que les femmes ont du
talent et puis aussi au reste du monde
qu'il y à des femmes peintres souvent
les oubliées elles existent berne
laury's marie laurencin et c'est une
balade en a des tas et qu'une femme peut
de nos jours marqué de son empreinte le
monde des arts pourquoi pas
et
alors c'est quoi ce rentable de l'homme
nu un peu idel parce que bon il est très
beau mais il n'existe pas il y en a un
qui est par là pour nous il existe en
tout cas dans mon imagination c'est
certes un bon ça c'est le travail du
psychanalyste évidemment d'analysé mais
mais mais mais peinture dans mes
peintures je me révèle c'est pour ça
j'avais une certaine pudeur justement à
faire voir ce que je peignais parce que
je sais qu on y découvre ma libido mes
faiblesses mes aspirations toutes ces
choses là
bon je payais beaucoup nu de dos au
départ c'est vrai d'abord des hommes
parce que bon j'avais su je vivais avec
un garçon qui posait pour moi donc il
posait tout nu de dos parce que j'avais
une certaine pudeur je trouvais que les
visages méritait d'être cachée parce
qu'on se révèle beaucoup plus à travers
son visage qu'à travers son physique
on est tous un petit peu pareil quand on
est tenus sur une plage alors que nos
yeux notre bouche exprimé immédiatement
sont refait notre âme
donc je vois les mes personnages les
masques et où je les faisais de dos bon
maintenant j'ai pris un petit peu plus
d'assurance c'est vrai que j'ai
découvert gauguin les impressionnistes
etc et je commence à peindre des
personnages de phase toujours nue plutôt
des hommes par par goût parce que j'aime
les beaux garçons viril je trouve que la
l'anatomie de l'homme est magnifique
mais ce n'est pas culturel chez vous
parce que finalement c'est très cérébral
vous vous donnez du luxe comme ça en
vous disant voilà je vais passer pour
une femme c'est érotique mais tout ce
que vous me dites là me fait croire que
dans la vie vous seriez plutôt quelqu'un
de pudique de sérieux et que tous leurs
espaces dans la sublimation artistique
dans les toiles dans les livres non je
pense que vous avez raison je suis ce
qu'on appelle cérébrale c'est à dire que
tout ça est dans ma tête et que j'ai des
fantasmes comme tous les artistes qui
passent uniquement sur mes toiles dans
ma peinture ou dans mon roman mais je
pas dans la vie réelle dans la veine
j'ai toujours une certaine pudeur
peut-être éducation parce que j'ai vécu
en angleterre etc
j'ai une certaine pudeur et une certaine
gêne même à parler ouvertement de choses
érotiques ou à faire même en tout cas en
public des choses qu'on fait dans le
privé je me défoule dans mes toiles en
peignant des personnages nus des
situations érotiques et alors du coup
j'ai cette réputation qu'on m'a cousue
dessus amanda lear femme vend entre
mangeuse d'hommes
érotique surtout les italiens alors une
petite fille tout à fait classique et
peut-être même
auriez vous quelques petits préjugés qui
reste parce qu'enfin vous dites les
hommes il faut les jeter comme ça comme
des kleenex
ce sont des formules et derrière ça vous
cacher quoi parce qu'enfin vous cacher
quelque chose de profond de géants de
morale je n'aime je n'aime pas me
découvrir non c'est vrai j'ai un masque
comme tout le monde quand on enlève le
masque etc on démystifie il amanda lear
qu'on connaît et a certainement en
dessous un autre masque de souffrance
en tout cas il ya autre chose qui n'a
rien à voir avec le premier masque la
première amanda lear c'est l'amanda
public scandaleuse sexy etc
il y en a une autre qui est beaucoup
plus intellectuel qui est beaucoup plus
spirituelle qui est chrétienne qui est
cultivé on y arrive et qui a presque
honte qui a presque honte de se laisser
prendre en flagrant délit
d'être intellectuelle parce que
justement je fais un métier bon la
chanson vous savez il faut pas très
intellectuel pour chanter je fais un
métier où pour être populaire
il faut pas être trop compliqué alors si
on commence à se montrer avec ses
angoisses est vrai que j'en ai ces
problèmes dans sa tête et où les gens
disent oh là là ça va aller trop
compliqué c'est pas possible
est-ce que vous avez des hommes
politiques vous devez connaître pas mal
d hallyday ce qui vous semble plus
érotique enfants seniors pouvoir ou pas
est-ce que ça compte ça mais je crois
que quand on a envie de coucher avec un
homme politique
ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas pau avec son parti oui on a
envie je crois de coucher avec le
pouvoir voilà c'est surtout ça qui est
excitant je pense et ses flammes qui ont
qui ont épousé des présidents de
républiques pas la jackie kennedy après
onassis après tout ce temps je pense que
ce qui les fascine c'est le pouvoir
c'est l'idée de cette position de force
s'est pas uniquement le fait qu'il est
sexy quand il déshabille le soir mais
c'est parce qu'il est sexy parce qu'il
est président de quelque chose c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est ce que vous est ce
que vous savez et et on voit le pouvoir
ne m'a jamais attiré ce qui m'a attiré à
une certaine époque que je peux
qualifier de période groupies de mon
existence
j'étais attiré par la popularité alors
je sortais des chanteurs je sortais avec
des acteurs de cinéma parce qu'ils
étaient célèbres et il y avait dans ce
côté groupie c'était pour dire à mes à
mes petites camarades à 20 mois j'ai été
avec intel et toi non
donc c'était une espèce de revanche
comme ça mais c'était pas des gens de
pouvoir c'est tes gens célèbres et puis
le jour où je suis devenu célèbre à
laurier le phénomène absolument
contraire du monde moi j'étais célèbre
je ne voulais plus rencontré que des
inconnus le livre que vous venez de
publier l'immortel vous abordez avec
courage trouve un thème intéressant ce
personnage qui re qui ne peut pas
vieilli parce que bon ya secret reste
toujours jeune et puis c'est un peu le
thème d'ailleurs de faust
mais revu par vous alors vous allez
mettre en scène vos vingt trente
prochaines années comment est ce que
vous y avez pensé aller cette sérénité
l'a bien sûr oui je pense qu'on
n'oubliera petit à petit mes frasques de
genèse mes erreurs du passé on oubliera
petit à petit que j'ai été soi-disant un
symbole sexuel en italie en tout cas et
petit à petit on dira oui mais
finalement derrière tous ses cheveux
derrière tout ça il y avait aussi un
petit cerveau qui fonctionnait et amanda
lear avait quelque chose à dire
et j'aime bien ce que cette bonne femme
a dans sa tête et alors là pour moi ce
sera une victoire
imagine-t-on amanda lear à une chaumière
de coeur bon est-ce qu'on peut aller
jusque là
pour ce qui est du jardin secret
toujours dans le plan des trente ans
d'amanda lear des 30 années à venir
c'est à dire jusqu'à 6 ans et randy
savage là je ne peux pas dire souvent je
pense qu'au contraire je finirai est
très seul je crois j'ai mon petit enfer
intérieur je me trimballe avec moi un
peu partout je pense que je ne vais pas
vraiment m'améliorer en vieillissant je
suis intolérant vous savez je suis
heureuse jalouse et possessive
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire tout le monde me tournait le dos
comme dans les premiers tableaux
d'ailleurs ou symboliquement mes modèles
me tourne le dos et je pense que je vais
me retrouver tout seul avec des chats
parce que j'adore les animaux des chats
des chiens des plantes et je serai deux
de ces vieilles dames difficile un peu
excentrique qui sortira la campagne avec
vous et puis voilà
[Musique]